lucky to have the um education secretary
gavin williamson with us
on the program this morning good morning
good morning one of those kids saying
it's too easy it's gonna be too easy
well i i accept that there'll be
criticism that way but i feel
what we've done is we put a package of
things together that's really fair for
children
i mean i i know having a a 16 year old
who's facing her gcses this year
uh who's had to self-isolate during this
term
is about making sure that there's a real
fair set of packages for students
just so they can do the very best for
themselves make sure they can actually
achieve
the very best grade that they really are
capable of doing so but how do you level
it because you know kids say in i don't
know in cornwall tier one they've gone
to school almost every
day whereas kids up in tier three
manchester uh up in the northeast as
well
less so their classes are being closed
they're having to go home again so
how do you how do you make it fair for
everybody well this is why we've
put this package of measures together
quite an exceptional package of measures
whether it's the announcements we made a
number of weeks ago about
moving exams back to give children extra
learning time so they can
have the opportunity to catch up whether
it's the extra billion pounds that we've
given to school so they can give
children extra lessons not just within
the school day but outside of a school
day as well
but the extra measures we've announced
today about the generosity
and grading making sure that children
have the best chance to achieve
the very best possible grade but also
the measures to ensure that they have
advanced notice of the topics that
they're going to be questioned on
they have exam aids with formula sheets
to ensure that if they have missed out
on some of that learning
they've got the information there so
they can use that information to do
very best so they can really focus in
their revision on the topics that are
going to matter
and this is going to make a big
difference and we think this is why we
spent the time
working with teachers working with
schools but also really importantly
listening to pupils to hear from what
they
have to say about what would help them
to do really well in exams and
actually be able to catch up where
they've missed out
can you give us a cast iron guarantee
that exams will not be cancelled
absolutely and what you're aware of but
many of your viewers probably haven't
actually been aware of is
even during this national lockdown we've
been running gcse exams
a-level exams and tens of thousands of
students have been taking those gcse and
a-level exams
all the way through that national
lockdown and that's been done
safely and securely and successfully so
i have every confidence if we've been
able to run
a whole set of exams for gcses and a
levels
during a national lockdown we have every
ability
to run those same set of exams in the
summer of next year
um if they've got all these aids they
will
undoubtedly get better grades surely
that just means that universities will
up the levels of exam results that you
need to get in
well we've been working very closely
with universities uk
and the russell group of universities
and all those universities who are
really wanting to
open their doors and welcome students
they want to be
welcoming as many of those students
through those doors and we'll be
continuing
a finite number of places there are a
finite number of places but what they
uh will see with children being able to
sit exams there's
a lot more rigor within the system than
we saw last year when
children weren't in a position to be
able to take those exams and what are
you going to do to make sure that that
happens that universities don't
make it even more difficult to get in
well we've been working with
universities
universities understand there's a real
obligation on them
to especially welcome students from more
disadvantaged backgrounds
backgrounds where maybe students
wouldn't have historically looked at
going to universities
and we've seen an increase in the number
of students going to university last
year
and we expect probably a similar
increase in number of students going to
university next year
universities have been able to expand
their places and welcoming more students
over the last year
i'm confident they're able to do the
same next universities
that are already students i should say
already at university this year
some of them not going back until
february but they still have to pay
their rent
so so that can't be fair so the
overwhelming
majority of students will be going back
during january
we've taken the tough decision to make
sure it's a staggered and staged return
all students when they get back to
university will be
offered a sort of non-symptomatic
test for covid to make sure we do
everything to ensure
their health but also their friends and
the community's health as well
but most students will be returning
during for january all those students
who have
practical lessons that they have to do
whether those training to be doctors
nurses engineers forty percent of those
students will be turning absolutely as
normal
and then over the following four five
weeks
all of the students will be done there
but it's really important
as we're as we're rolling out uh the
testing for
every student it's making sure that
there's a steady flow of students coming
into the university so those
sort of tests can be administered yeah
but my question is uh what about those
that are going back in february can't go
back until february they still have to
pay their rent you know students are
notoriously as poor as church mice
that can't be fair well that's why we
announced an extra
20 million pounds to support students
who need
that extra bit of help who are suffering
as a consequence so they can use that
money
they can appeal for that money yeah so
20 million pounds is going to be
distributed to universities to help
students affected by this
so students that are not going back
until february can benefit from that
amount of money yeah there's 20 million
pounds that's being put there to support
okay what's the dropout rate like well
at the moment we haven't got the data in
terms of dropout rates uh
we're very confident that we want to
we've been
putting all so much effort into reducing
dropout rates over the last few years
and the office for students which is the
regulator of the universities
is working very closely with university
to make sure that it's obviously within
the students interest but
equally very much within the
university's interest as well
to keep students in university this is
why we've protected education settings
whether it's schools colleges or
universities keeping them open
during a national lockdown because we
recognize that if
students are dropping out they're
missing out on some amazing life chances
can we talk about the vaccine um
can we completely rule out another
national lockdown
well we none of us want to see a
national lockdown and
none of us expect to see a national
lockdown and with the
the fact that we're going to be rolling
out a vaccine the fisa vaccine
before christmas and we have had such
promising sort of progress on the
astrazeneca university of oxford vaccine
yeah
with a hundred million doses of that
vaccine uh going to be heading our way
once it's got regulatory approval
i have every confidence that we can see
the light at the end of the tunnel and
this should go
you know people continue to take that
responsible approach of the british
people have shown
all the way through this pandemic i have
every confidence that we won't be seeing
another national lockdown okay
um we did hear from the prime minister
and also indeed
from the health sector yesterday both
saying that we'll be out of this
by the spring we need two vaccinations
don't we so are you confident that the
whole nation
will have had two vaccinations by the
spring
well what we're seeing is that we're
targeting those who are most vulnerable
those people who are most
likely to be in hospital and who most
likely
be affected in terms of their uh
surviving covid so quite rightly we're
targeting those people first
i'm confident that we've rolled out of
the vaccine
especially targeted those vulnerable
people will be in a position where we
will defeat
virus and we will have defeated the
virus by the spring yes yeah
will everybody in the nation have had
two vaccinations by the spring
uh well it's um over the coming uh
months we're going to see the roll out
further plans will be outlined
uh it'd be wrong with me to preempt that
announcement of all those plans
and the announcement of regulatory
approval for other vaccines until that's
been
firstly got through for regulatory
approval stage and those plans have been
outlined to the house of commons would
you have a vaccine live on telly it
seems to be the trend at the moment
uh well when it's maintained for what
you say
we may make you do it here well i i i'm
sure your viewers have better things to
watch for me having a vaccine
live on tv and by the time it gets to uh
my turn to have a vaccine i imagine i'll
be pretty far down for pecking orders
there's a lot more
important people to have a vaccine
before me but if
if if you really think your viewers
would be that interest to see me have a
vaccine i'm sure i would do it but
i i think i i i make a note of that i
think
it would be so uninteresting to so many
people and so many people would have had
it we'll be the judge of that
uh let me talk to you about um takeaways
in uh so-called wet pubs can you do it
or not
uh take away and you have a takeaway
ordered to a wet pub
so if you don't serve food in the pub
can you order a takeaway and
um drink it and eat in the pub you you
should always be eating the food in the
pub
as i know i've got many brilliant pubs
in my constituency
and i know that they always have a rule
of making sure that you uh
eat uh food that you purchase on the
premises what if they don't sell
food on the premises can you order a
takeaway there's there's got to be a
substantial
uh meal with yeah and and and the pub's
really got to be providing that meal yes
okay so you don't
if you can't order a takeaway and have
it delivered to the public but
the pub's got to be providing that meal
okay what about if the landlord buys it
uh well if the pub is providing that
meal uh via the landlord i'm sure
i'm sure that would be the case but it's
about the pub providing the substantial
meal
with the alcohol okay so the landlord
could order the takeaway for you that's
interesting
um and as far as brexit is concerned
quick thought on that
if you wouldn't mind um how are the
negotiations going
i ask all of your colleagues all of the
time we really are drinking in the last
chance to learn if i can continue on
with the theme
well we always expect negotiations to go
up to the wire it's a very typical sort
of a
situation when you're sort of having a
negotiation with the european union
but the fact that negotiations continue
to go i'm
confident that uh from what i hear that
progress
good progress has been made but we are
going to do a deal that's
right for britain if such a deal is
available
but if such a deal isn't available then
we're not going to sign up to something
that's to our detriment
um how come reshuffle coming how
confident are you of keeping your job
you could be health secretary next and
then
you definitely have to have your jab on
the telly well as i say i i don't want
to damage your viewing figures by
having my vaccination done on television
but um
um everyone's focus everyone's focused
in actually delivering
on the issues and on their portfolio so
my focus is making sure that children
wherever they live in the country get
the very best education and we've seen
before return of school since september
we saw 1.6 million children going to
school before the summer
that's our focus driving up standards
we've got so much that we're doing in
terms of skills in terms of our further
education colleges
the amazing work that our universities
are doing whether it's developing new
vaccines
or making sure that 50 percent of
children that go to university
uh get the very best education that's
where our focus is on
not um speculation finally um i know
that you have family experience of
concerns about covid what does that mean
for you
at christmas time it's a challenge for
everybody i know
like so many people we're sort of not
quite sure i think it's really good that
we've got this set of guidelines where
people can have the opportunity to be
able to mix with families
uh but it's about doing it responsibly
and uh
we're we're sort of still excited yet um
we haven't decided my mum
um you know is is one of those who um
you know as uh
vulnerable as my dad as a uh getting
a little bit older and uh you're always
wanting to put their safety first uh
but like so many of us yeah you're just
sort of so desperate to see family as so
many of us have
you know gone for so long without
spending that time with our loved ones
michael gove's invited me around for
christmas i could have a word if you
like
well i i i i i i couldn't really compete
with that but you're very welcome to
come up to
wolverhampton and spend christmas with
the williamson family if you if you want
to be part of our
our christmas football more than welcome
but you do have to bring a present
okay i'll bring a very very big bottle
of wine how does that
that sounds absolutely excellent it's
good to see you thanks for joining us we
appreciate it